[Music]
thank you
Ukraine has launched an effective
counter-offensive against Russia in the
last few weeks winning thousands of
square miles back from Putin's Army so
what exactly is happening on the front
line I'm joined Now by spectator
contributor Emma Matthews who writes in
this week's magazine about the ultra
right-wing nationalist who would be
likely to take over from Putin if he
were removed from power and Mike Martin
a former British Army soldier and the
author of why we fight
so oh Matthews and Mike Martin thank you
for coming on to spectator TV now Mike
tell us about the latest in the Russian
invasion of Ukraine because it does
sound like Ukraine's uh fighting back
and quite effectively over the last week
or so
yeah thanks Cindy it's it's actually a
really significant moment um so over the
last five or six days or so the
ukrainians have taken about 9 000 square
kilometers of territory liberated I
should say
um from the Russian occupying forces and
in that area of the country in the
Northeast they've pushed the Russians
right back to the border and and quite
significantly they've captured a couple
of major Logistics hubs and Logistics
routes that Supply the Russian forces in
not just in that northeastern part of
the country but also in the donbass in
the East where we had all those big
battles a couple of months ago so this
is a huge setback for the Russian forces
both militarily but I think perhaps more
importantly psychologically because it's
it's really really created some ripples
both within the military and also within
Moscow and have they managed to do this
because it has been six months in the
war so far
you know they're just better than what
um over the last couple of months
they've been building up and signaling
that they're going to be launching this
big offensive in the South and her son
um and that's you know a really
important area that the ukrainians need
to take back because it's it's it's on
the way to Crimea and Crimea is the the
most important part of Ukraine for
Russia you know that's the last bit that
they want to lose it's their strategic
center of gravity and because the
ukrainians have been signaling in that
direction and then about a month ago
they launched this curse on offensive
that's quite well covered in our media
um the Russians rushed loads of troops
down into her son and they stripped them
out from places like the donbass but
also in haki where we've seen this
offensive and so those thinned out
Russian lines uh basically the
ukrainians just punched through them and
then had very very fast mechanized
forces
um so infantry on on Fast vehicles that
basically went behind through the
Russian lines and then took out the
logistics dance I've just spoken about
caused the Russian lines to collapse so
actually the ukrainians didn't need to
fight every last Russian solder they
just collapsed their Logistics and they
come under control and then in in loads
of places the Russians just turned and
ran away and abandoned all of their
equipment
oh and in The Wider scheme of things
what does this mean for the war because
it's actually optimistic to think that
this is going to be in the last few
months of the war will Russia you know
surrender
well there's actually two different
um planes on which this war actually is
being fought one of them is actually the
reality on the ground which Mike has
actually described very well and
accurately every and then there's the
public perception in Moscow and
um
frankly
um there has been you know a certain
amount of bickering on various uh TV and
Kremlin TV talk shows and so on about
who is to blame and so on but in this
ground scheme of things the Kremlin is
actually taking a really interesting
line and that is you know that the war
basically doesn't exist
so last week Vladimir Putin gave a uh a
40-minute very boring speech on
economics to the Vladivostok um you know
Far Far Eastern forum and Vladivostok
and that in its in and of itself is
important that he actually decided the
most important thing he could talk about
was economics for 40 minutes and didn't
mention War once
um and he obliquely referred to sort of
difficulties and new situations and so
on but like but also more importantly
not a single word about sort of
patriotism
so um I think actually the it's it's
very significant that Kremlin actually
has sort of decided to play this down
enormously and at the beginning I mean
there's various you know rumors flare up
from time to time that Putin needs to
announce a full mobilization uh that's
the only way he's going to win this war
but I'm sure I mean Mike is better
qualified to talk to me to talk than I
am about this but I mean mobilization
doesn't really help Putin on the ground
he doesn't really need more untrained
people furthermore as we know from
various sort of military bloggers a lot
of the uh tactical battalions in every
division that are so the training
battalions in every division that are
actually there to train our conscripts
have actually been deployed to Ukraine
so there's actually no one to train the
new people but the bottom line is that
actually in Moscow in Russia no one has
noticed and no one cares now that's uh
and as we know they've lost
um last I heard Brazilian was from
zielinski with six Mike just said nine
thousand square kilometers uh we have to
bear in mind that overall the Russians
have taken about 120 depending on how
you count it but like they were
currently occupy about 21 just before
the Holocaust front collapsed and that's
roughly speaking about 120 130 000
square kilometers of territory so in the
ground scheme of things they've maybe
lost you know
um 80 of that and none of it was
actually particularly Grand that they
were actually planning to keep and they
were I think suddenly planning to
negotiate away their gains in
hardcopopolis what they really want is
Don bass and what they really want is
the mariopol corridor that links uh
Crimea to donbass and the indications
are that they're actually planning to
negotiate away here so on but the
ukrainians may do that for them by
taking it first and so Mike's still
still an uphill battle then for Ukraine
from here
yeah I like it's not gonna end before
winter but um I think it's definitely on
the table that the war might end next
summer
um I remember coming on Spectators TV
about six months ago and you read out
one of my tweets that said uh I'm gonna
call this Ukraine's gonna win it and
that will be followed by the end of
Putin in Russia and I still think that's
the case I think the fundamentals are
that you know the three most important
things of warfare in Warfare a strategy
Logistics and morale and on all those
three scores Ukraine is doing much
better and is in the ascendancy and
Russia is the opposite and it is in is
descending on those on those criteria
um it there are some key questions right
at the moment that the route of the
Russian forces in the Northeast are they
going to be able to stabilize that front
line they've tried to do it behind a
river called the river or school
um I think that's been breached in a
couple of places so that's a big
question where they stabilize the front
line and then the second question the
immediate question is whether the
ukrainians have got a reserve with which
they can sustain that attack if not I
think nothing's going to happen before
winter winter is going to be you know a
naturally military activity dies down in
Winter Logistics are much more difficult
so on and so forth and then we're
looking at next spring and assuming the
ukrainians are going to use the winter
to train up rearm you know generate a
reserve then I expect to see another
offensive from the ukrainians and you
know to date they've been much more
agile than the Russians have been on the
battlefield and that's been you know one
of the key advantages that they've had
over the Russians Owen I want to come to
you very shortly about Putin's domestic
situation
um but before I do that you know one
question I always have when we're
talking about the situation on the front
line is how much we can believe what's
coming out of the Ukrainian government
because obviously you know this is a
side of the West is supporting but we
have seen that the government has picked
up for obvious reasons for morale
reasons uh successes so when reporting
or when analyzing a situation what what
how do you decipher uh what's to be
relied on what's not
uh well the answer to that is pretty
simple you just
um follow the pro Russian bloggers and
uh people on Twitter so there's actually
um and very interestingly there's
actually um several Rebel commanders
from the Don bass who have actually been
very vocal one of them is called
Alexander hodakovski not to be confused
with Mikhail hodorokowski
um and igusted in a various sort of
commanders are on the ground or still
covers not on the ground but he was
Former Defense Minister of the DNR and
they are constantly posting I don't know
where they get them but constantly
posting these uh uh Drone footage and
Battlefield footage and you know the you
know the uh you know headcam footage
because it's become you know it's it's
very much a sort of GoPro war and also
there's a lot of
um of official Russian correspondence on
the ground and also various sort of uh
Wing nuts including Graham Phillips our
very own British wing nut who's out
there
um who uh you know who is producing some
you know um I'm not incredibly reliable
information but certainly some
information in in interesting metrics on
the ground about you know what the
soldiers are saying and so on and the
really interesting thing is that lots of
the supposedly pro-russian uh commanders
and Don bass have actually just been
saying you know we were betrayed we
haven't got the logistics you know
there's actually a lot of discontent and
anger and one of the points about my
article is that actually you know these
people who are currently you know hand
and faced with fighting on the ground
with the Russian forces are actually in
a very scary people there's a lot of
very extreme right-wingers among them
there's lots of extreme nationalists
among them and um
um right now they um the fact that
already they're speaking out and you
know Kremlin TV you know state-sponsored
TV
um uh correspondence to speaking out is
also is actually quite significant it
means that things are really bad so it
doesn't really um you know necessarily
confirm everything that the ukrainians
are saying and I think the ukrainians
are actually slightly prone to
exaggeration especially if you look at
the Ukrainian defense Ministry Like
official ticker
um and I think it's like 49 700 or
something was the last thing of you know
Russian deaths on the ground I mean I
suspect that's a little bit exaggerated
but nonetheless I mean the
um what they're generally saying about a
breakthrough is undoubtedly true
well Evan let's look at pictures
situation then because
um as you as you mentioned so far uh he
seems to have made some kind of
Coalition an informal care relation with
the ultra nationalists and actually you
write that as these Ultra nationalists
who could be causing him more headache
now than the Liberals like Alexia
navalny that we in the west know so much
about
yeah the the Liberals are not a headache
they're not even like you know they're
they're not even a sort of you know a
vague thought in the in the minds of the
Kremlin they they're absolutely not
serious as a an opposition and certainly
there is 0.0 chance that they the
liberal opposition will succeed Putin
that is literally not going to happen I
mean and actually for instance the last
time that Alexander van needs who's very
often described on the BBC and so on as
you know the head of the Russian
opposition when they've only lost
actually stood for public election a
public office as a local Deputy in
Moscow we actually stood for mayor of
Moscow
um back in the early 2010s in 2011 I
think it was he received 20 and I've
only got 20 of the vote in Moscow so
that gives you a sense of how
electorally insignificant they are even
you know in his power base he gets 20 no
so the much more scary thing and it's
not necessarily an electoral threat but
it's the fact that these people are
armed motivated and highly angry
potentially the Kremlin and will become
more so if there is you know Battlefield
defeat are the ultra Nationalist
paramilitaries and um what's really
scary and I think that the point we
really need to to emphasize is the
threat is not that these people are
going to seize power I mean it's
possible it might seems power the
Bolshevik sees power with just a few
thousand people in in October 1917. so
it's not they're going to seize power
it's what the Kremlin and the people
around Putin are going to do to prevent
them from becoming a threat is the
vector in which the Kremlin has to go in
order to appease these angry nationalist
people and that is the real there's a
real threat so Mike actually mentioned
you know Russia about Putin and I think
a lot of people especially Western
capitals certainly in Emmanuel macron
um I know for a fact because I've spoken
to one of his advisors at some length
about this
um are actually rather scared about what
Russia without Putin will look like and
equally the the the the direct extension
of that is they're scared of giving
Ukraine too many weapons and two and
weapons that are too powerful and just
to give you a very precise idea of how
few weapons Ukraine is getting
um I'm not sure what the exact suddenly
like a few weeks ago they were operating
with 24 High Mars multiple rocket
systems that uh that launch high
accuracy Rockets 24 is what the
Americans gave the ukrainians in May the
Polish Army ordered 500.
so 500 high miles is what like a
medium-sized European Army requires for
its operational needs in peacetime 500.
the ukrainians have been given 24 in
Wartime so that really shows how
incredibly limited the military support
really has been and how and the reason
for that is because they're scared of
actually inflating a catastrophic
Battlefield defeat because they don't
want to cause another Russian Revolution
that's a real concern I mean it's
fascinating what you say about macron's
advisor telling you about this Weimar
Republic comparison because of course it
was post-war post first world war
Germany that led to Hitler
um it was fascinating calculus going on
here Mike what happens if Putin feels
like he has been cornered on the
battlefield because there is a lot of
talk about possibly is this when he uh
turns towards what's called a tactical
nuclear attack you know could that
happen
I so I think that there is a lot of talk
about that
um I think the thing about tactical
nuclear weapons is is there's no such
thing right all all nuclear weapons are
strategic and if your opponent loses and
uses a nuclear weapon you don't go oh
it's just a small one so that's why
they're all they're all nuclear weapons
um
for a long time now since the second
world war we've we collectively you know
the Russians the the nuclear Powers have
operated under these Norms of non-use of
tactical attacks you got me doing it of
nuclear weapons and we do that because
of mutually assured destruction right if
somebody uses them then somebody else is
gonna gonna deliver a response my
reading of the situation is that uh a
Putin doesn't know if he uses a nuclear
weapon what the response will be there's
three nuclear Powers working against him
France Britain and America I'm sure
there's a lot of conversations under the
table that we're not aware of but the
use of a nuclear weapon on what is
effectively European soil I simply don't
see how America Britain and France can
allow that to stand so I think the
calculation in Putin's head will be well
if I use a nuclear weapon I can't be
sure at all that I Will Survive that use
of that nuclear weapon in terms of
retaliation or whether or whether you
know bits of Russia will also not
survive and I I think certainly he would
be ejected from Power if not killed in
some way and I I just think that that's
his calculation they are losing the war
slowly and it's hard to see how a
nuclear weapon helps them win that war
and we haven't even seen the use of
chemical weapons for instance which you
know we saw Assad you know Russia's
closed captioning not available
[Music]
thank you
[Music]